mario roy cherche sa mère depuis 14 ans
après de multiples démarches il l'a
enfin trouvée il y a deux semaines au
cimetière de sorel françoise chrétien
est décédé en 2002 elle aurait 90 ans
cette année
qu'est ce que vous savez sur votre mère
or c'est un très très bon vivant ça
c'est sûr puis à verser jamais marie mai
à niamey la vie et votre mère est ce qu
elle était belle oui belle femme et elle
s'est jamais marié non comme des
pressions que nous regarde
amine a également appris que sa mère est
morte en 2012
j'avais beau me dire il reste mon père
c'est pas pareil
un père oui c'est plaisant mais quand on
fera passer ma demande c'est papa pour
paul
cette nouvelle est d'autant plus
douloureuse qu'elle le vit comme un
nouvel abandon ses parents biologiques
se sont mariés quelques semaines après
l'avoir donnée en adoption
elle a tenté de les contacter par la
suite mais sans succès ils ont refusé
quand même le contact après deux
semaines de réflexion il en pleurait
c'était surtout que leurs enfants
étaient au courant et qu' il n'y avait
pas que je leur reproche
cet abandon l'eau sa fille aînée valérie
a vécu ce moment pénible aux côtés de sa
mère on n'a pas pour la suisse aussi
mais d'un autre fut un autre et j'ai
fait je pense pas pour ma mère vincent
duluc qui a fait sa demande de
retrouvailles dès le lendemain de
l'adoption de la loi n'a reçu pour
l'instant qu'un accusé de réception des
services sociaux de la montérégie
il avait déjà eu un début de réponse au
tournant des années 2000
cinq femmes avaient été approchés tout
avait nié l'existence d'un fils laissé à
l'adoption de plusieurs scénarios
possibles
on n'a pas fait jamais rencontré d'abord
nous sommes sérieux on peut l'avoir
rencontré que la nié toute appartenance
à nouveau le troisième qui est assez
fréquent c'est un faux nom il est
possible en fait que sa mère soit
toujours vivante d'atteinte pas de
nouvelle bonne nouvelle
selon la loi 113 seul le nom du parent
recherché et divulguer les personnes
adoptées doivent ensuite se débrouiller
tout seul pour trouver toutes les autres
informations et les parents biologiques
s'ils vivent toujours ont un an pour
enregistrer un refus de retrouvailles le
centre des services sociaux de la
montérégie a été débordé dès la première
semaine
derrière ces portes fermées huit
employés répondent aux demandes de tout
le québec
les gens attendaient cette journée du
mois de juin où les lignes ont ouvert
donc il ya eu un nombre important
d'appels dans la première semaine on a
reçu 14 mai à peine plusieurs personnes
avaient appelé des dizaines de fois
selon madame morneau qui se fient à des
statistiques sur les deux cent mille
enfants laissés à l'adoption depuis 1940
au québec seulement 5 % vont
entreprendre des démarches
chacune des demandes par contre doit
être analysée avec une grande rigueur
c'est sûr que ce comprenez que les
informations qu'on transmet vont changer
la vie des gens vont changer la vie de
la personne adoptées vont changer la vie
de la personne qui a donné son nom à un
enfant l'adoption
donc on peut pas avoir des rares
pour mario roy la quête de sa famille
naturelle n'est pas terminée c'est pour
finir c'est encore je trouvais magar
totalement prêts si je caprins
en attendant il a retrouvé des cousines
pour son plus grand bonheur
paul espère une réponse positive de son
père je saurai vous dire avait atteint
augment livre grain comme source
moi je suis prête à recevoir cette
grande famille je prête à les commettre
mais enfin sont prêts à l'écart est
aussi pu remarquer quelqu'un bon c'est
des points ou des bons enfants
j'ai quand même mieux de s'en faire une
belle ligne et banca ton arbre
généalogique
qu'est ce qu'on ferait pas quant à
vincent
si vous retrouvez votre mère et qu'elle
est vivante vous lui dites quoi tim a
énormément manqué